- [Narrator] Take a Pagan festival,
chariots pulled by bikes, and
a tiny Welsh town, and you get
whatever this is.
(circus music)
This story takes place
in the Welsh countryside,
in the town of Llanwrtyd?
Llanwrtyd?
- Llanwrtyd Wells.
We are the smallest town in the UK.
- [Narrator] And this
is Lindsay Ketteringham.
He runs the local hotel in town.
- [Lindsay] It's called
the Neuadd Arms Hotel.
The town today is a small
farming community primarily.
Everybody knows everybody else.
Day-to-day life is generally
pretty quiet around here.
- [Narrator] Except on event day.
- The Mountain Bike
Chariot Racing Championship
is an event that was
conceived to be part of
a Roman festival that
we hold each January.
The rules of the race are to get round
in the fastest time possible.
The course starts off on
a short tarmac stretch,
then becomes a rough, stony
road with puddles and bumps,
and eventually comes back to the finish
along a tarmac stretch
which has speed bumps.
It's not a simple task.
We do encourage people to
dress up as the Romans did.
As you can see, people
enter into the spirit of it,
which is what it's all about.
- [Narrator] Okay, but
Ben-Hur style bike racing
isn't everything that this tiny town does.
- [Lindsay] We do the events
such as Man versus Horse, Bog Snorkelling.
- [Narrator] And it all
started back in the seventies.
Llanwrtyd Wells was the
center of the pony trekking
industry in Britain, and in
the 1970's unfortunately,
the industry went into serious decline.
At that point the local
business people started looking
for ideas to boost the economy,
and came up with the idea
of running events, things
that were slightly different
and unusual.
It's great to see the
success of the events,
see people enjoying themselves,
and it's great to be able to share what
this part of the countryside has to offer.
The aim is to maintain
the great community that
we have here, even to help
it grow, but not too much.
We don't want to lose
our smallest town status.
- [Narrator] Hey, I hear you Lindsay.
(soft ding)